hello everyone
thanks for joining and welcome to actin
flab
live stream number 24.1 today it's june
22 2021 and we're going to be discussing
the paper and empirical evaluation of
active inference in multi-armed bandits
with several of the authors so thanks
everyone for joining
welcome to the active inference lab we
are a participatory
online lab that is communicating
learning and practicing applied active
inference
you can find us at the links here on
this screen
this is recorded in an archived live
stream so please provide us with
feedback
so that we can improve on our work all
backgrounds and perspectives
are welcome here and we'll be following
good video etiquette for live streams
this short link has a schedule of all
the live streams that we've been doing
and will do for 2021
and we're here today on june 22nd in
number 24.1
which is the middle of the three-part
series on this paper about multi-armed
bandits
the zero video 24.0 had
some context and some background on this
paper that we're going to be
discussing an empirical evaluation of
active inference in multi-armed
bandits and today we're here with
three of the authors so thanks so much
for all of you who are joining today
because we'll have a lot to discuss and
learn about and
in today's discussion for 24.1
we're gonna first just go for some
introductions and then we're going to
have
a presentation by the author and then
we're going to just open it up for
discussion so if you're
here on the video call or if you're
watching
live in the live chat just feel free to
ask any question
and we can go wherever people are
interested
in going so that being said here we are
in the introductions
we'll just go around and introduce
ourselves and
say hello and then especially for the
authors who are joining for the first
time
it'd be awesome to hear anything you
want to
say or we'll ask you questions as well
so
i'm daniel i'm a postdoctoral researcher
in california and i'll pass to
dave i'm
in the tropical mountainous rainforest
120 miles north of manila
my background is in cybernetic learning
theory
general psychology and machine
translation
but not much math so i'm floundering
with much of the active inference
world we'll go to sarah
and then continue on
i'm sarah i'm a postdoc in treeson
together with tim t
my original background is physics and
biophysics
but i wrote my dissertation essentially
about active inference
and especially applied to habit learning
and yeah that's it for me
and going on to dimitri
should we let her introduce himself i
don't know i'm not sure if he wants to
do that
okay i mean i can also introduce him
shortly so
there was our colleague from ucl
previously so he worked in max planck
ucl center for computational psychiatry
and aging research and currently he has
switched to industry so he is working in
second mind
uh on the applied reinforcement learning
there so
basically he is a expert on this other
part of staffordshire
which doesn't cover active inference
right
so and uh yeah i'm also the postdoc
technical university of dresden uh both
me and sarah are at the chair for neuro
imaging
uh where like the head of the chair is
stefan kiebel
uh and and uh yeah we have been involved
with active inference for a while now
since probably 2015-16
and have been applying it to various
questions regarding human behavior
cognitive control decision making in
dynamic environments and similar
um and yes so um
should they kind of switch to the slides
now or
sure we can go to the students or if i
can just ask one
general question to any of the authors
who wanted to respond
was it that you were interested in
active inference and then
looking for domains to apply it in
or were you interested in a domain and
then sort of found
active inference as a way to integrate
what you were working on
i yeah well i mean so my background is
also like right in physics
complex systems uh and computational
neuroscience and this physicist we like
to
think about this unifying theories so
in this sense active inference has this
appeal that it can collect
connect a very kind of distinct way of
basically thinking about decision making
thermodynamics um right uh stochastics
dynamics and
uh very kind of different areas of
of understanding dynamical systems so to
say
uh and kind of in control so that
that would be the appeal and uh right uh
i mean definitely uh as a tool to apply
like to decision making human
understanding human behavior
this is kind of where this all started
right
so what new can we learn basically
uh using this approach
and sarah any thoughts about especially
i'm curious about the biology side
because we hear a lot about the
math and the physics verging towards
active inference but it's also cool to
hear about biology and that was
my background as well my background is
rather in biophysics
so i'm only tangentially in biology
but what i like is also that it connects
with some general information processing
scheme in the brain
and actually my masters see this i was
working way way down
in the abstraction hierarchy on spiking
neural networks and like receptor
dynamics
and actually in this area i find it easy
to not see the forest for the trees
and i think actually connecting upwards
and asks the question what is a general
information processing that's going on
and then connecting it back downwards
again is what also
attracted me to active influence
awesome so as usual people will be uh
i guess joining or leaving i'll unshare
this
screen and dimitri if you want to uh
jump into the presentation that'd be
awesome
yes
okay so you see yeah
and uh all crop everything so go for it
excellent okay so
let me start with a bit kind of
motivation for this work uh
so as well you realize kind of our
involvement with active inference
came from this kind of cognitive
neuroscience
uh direction uh
and originally not so interested in the
technicals or machine learning side of
it
uh however if one thinks about uh
multi-arm problem bandits right that's a
very general uh
problem which kind of generalizes
resource allocation problems
then when they realize that this is most
of kind of behavioral
experiments can be cast into this kind
of framework right
and once these this in the range of kind
of uh
extreme experimental cognitive
neuroscience uh
domains like decision-making in dynamic
environments
value-based decision-making structure
learning and similar uh
one can also think about like um
attention
as a resource allocation problem right
so it's
kind of there are many other domains
where
maybe they're not explicitly talking
about multi-arm bandits
as such but they can also be cast uh
into this uh
general framework and for example for
from decision making dynamic
environments one of the most
well-known kind of tasks is a
probably like reversal learning task
right that's kind of used in uh
hundreds of papers and this is also kind
of
what initially motivated me to make this
paper
uh it's a kind of just uh understanding
so if i apply active inference to liver
reversal learning tasks how does this
compare to other
like alternative decision making uh
approaches we can apply to that right
however right besides this kind of
cognitive neuroscience uh
uh direction uh multiple bandits have
like a range of industrial applications
uh they really use like
you know starting from marketing to
finance like recommendation systems in
finance for trading applications
uh i even in many like optimization
problems in the
like deep learning right you know there
are lots of
papers actually showing how you can
speed up learning by
um uh finding kind of better sets of
examples for
uh for the deep learning uh uh
systems uh and right so basically the
way this also kind of
allows them active inference to bridge
this into a machine learning gap and
find
new uh applications there if it's fine
if it kind of shows to be useful for
this kind of multi-armored setup
as kind of adding something new to the
existing work
right and
when we talk kind of multi-arm bandits
have a
range of different formulations
today we will talk about stationary
bandits and dynamic bandits
uh where just means that uh reward
probabilities either are fixed over time
or change
uh in different ways however people also
write uh
discuss adversarial bandits risk of air
bandits uh contextual bandits
one can also talk about non-markovian
bandits or that
kind of rewards uh depend on a sequence
of actions or
have kind of some memory dependence in
the system
and so on right they're really like a
range of
different uh kind of structural
definitions of multi-arm bandits which
kind of then require a different way of
thinking about the problem
uh and this is potentially like
something uh also interesting for the
future
expanding uh what we did here uh into
this
other domains and seeing if again this
the results are generalizable to other
uh
definitions of multi-unbending problems
uh okay so just
um how i structure the slide so far
we have like two parts one isn't about
stationary bandits
and then we will switch which will go to
switching bandits
yeah uh and uh yeah given that we have
two hours i hope that will be enough
time but
if yeah if not we can also continue for
the next session
for example with switching bandits or so
let's see let's see how this goes
um okay so what is stationary bandit so
the
definition of the problem is as follow
right on any trial
an agent makes a choice between k-pops
uh choice outcomes are binary variables
so we kind of focus here on bernoulli
bandits
outcomes can also be drawn from any
other distribution so
and then for example you talk about
gaussian bandits or
uh yeah depending on the under how the
rewards are
generated we will just uh work with
bernoulli here
here bandits and we have
we have fixed uh reward probabilities in
a very specific way
so there is only one arm which has a
reward probability associated with p max
which is one half
plus some uh term epsilon like which is
larger than zero and all other uh
um all reward probabilities associated
with other arms are just fixed to one
half
but this kind of allows us to
like control the difficulty of the task
so because the
more smaller the epsilon is the closer
to zero is uh the more difficult is to
distinguish the best arm from
from others and the more samples one he
needs to draw to kind of realize the
difference right
uh and right beside this like the best
arm advantage term
uh one also realizes that right number
of
arms k is also increasing the difficulty
the more arms you have the more time you
need to figure out
what is the correct arm to play okay
so just to give you an illustration of
the example right we have
forearm banded here uh
so whenever kind of agent pulls one of
the arms uh it gets
it gets either zero or one so we can
think of this as a
reward or absence of a reward right
uh beliefs about the reward
probabilities uh we will assume that
right these are beta distributed so we
will use beta distribution to model kind
of
a representation of reward probabilities
associated with each arm
and we will use um bayesian belief
updating for
all action selection algorithms so this
also kind of limits
uh the range of algorithms which we want
to compare
here in this study
i will explain a bit uh later
why i mean we focus on that
uh so
just to give you a kind of visual
example of what this does
is right uh whenever an arm kind of
an agent starts with with kind of flat
beliefs over
reward probabilities associated with
each
arm so this is like a uniform
distribution
uh this is a special case of beta
and whenever uh it pulls like selects
one arm
uh it gets uh either one or zero as an
outcome
and it updates right uh the beliefs
about the reward probabilities uh in
one of the directions right uh so
in here right we're kind of it's
sampling one more often so it
has increased belief that there is a
higher reward probability
associated associated with this
uh so formally how
this is kind of implemented what you see
here
is like to a very simple you know
generative model uh
so with each k arm we assume there is
some associated
unknown reward probability that okay
which is just a number between zero and
one
and uh choice outcomes of choices are
either zero or one so they're just
binary choices
so this kind of constraints are like uh
observation likely
to a bernoulli distribution so this is
just kind of
product of different bernoulli
distribution depending on which arm one
is selecting
and this kind of uh term below like this
is
our prior belief about reward
probabilities
and this will assume is just kind of
product of uh many uh
beta distributions where here alpha zero
and beta0 are just fixed to one so this
corresponds to the uniform
right right one can also start with
other values but uh
i think this makes some sense again
reflects uh no knowledge a priori about
report
uh so now given some choice at
trial t80 uh we just apply
by subject rule and we get from some
prior beliefs
uh a posterior beliefs and then i think
about the stationary case is if
our priors are beta distributed our
posteriors will be also
beta distributed and the update
one only needs to take care about how we
update write the
parameters of beta distribution alpha
and beta
and this just works in a form of
accounting basically
alpha counts how many times you observe
one as an outcome and beta counts how
many times you
observe zero
and so because of all this uh in this
stationary case
inference is uh exact so that because
both prior and possible belong to the
same distribution family you have kind
of conjugate prior
here setup so you can just track
effectively
the updating there is another kind of
uh representation of the update rules
one can use here so for example
if we express the updating in terms of
expected kind of outcome mu
and the scale parameter nu here we see
that actually the expectations are
updated in the form of a
delta like learning room so right where
this kind of learning rate is something
which decreases over time so basically
new is just increasing over time
whenever you select specific
arm and you will just increase by one
and this means that the learning rate
decreases over time so
the more you sample from one arm the
less you will update
your beliefs about it all right so this
is uh
in practically what's happening here
very very simple um
okay so and uh basically this is
everything we need to know about kind of
this uh
let's call it perceptual part of the
generity model so how we update beliefs
given some
outcomes now we have to kind of
introduce how we select actions right
based on these beliefs and for this
right i
we kind of can talk about action
selection algorithms
and so uh
uh they are in kind of in the literature
there are lots of red examples one of
the oldest one is probably epsilon
greedy
you also mention it during the first
[Music]
presentation point zero tyler people
also talk about right uh ucb
uh upper confidence bound this is also
one of the oldest one
kl ucb uh it's kind of extension which
uses uh
kl as uh exploration okay kl divergence
is a
estimate of exploration uh bound
there is thompson sampling etc uh here
we will
focus mostly on on this
tree right we will use the optimistics
thompson sampling
as a one kind of comparative example and
another is bayesian upper confidence
bound
so first both of these algorithms have
been extensively
analyzed in the literature and people
just find something
they work in in many examples lots a lot
much better than kind of let's say
non-bayesian approaches
uh and secondly right we can
use basically for all three algorithms
the same uh
update rules because they are just
bayesian uh
they're just algorithms corresponding to
bayesian and bandits so
we can kind of our motivation here is to
compare kind of
action selection principles based on the
uh
action selection algorithm and not based
on potentially different ways how you
update beliefs about
uh about the history of observations
right
and uh so right this would be kind of uh
motivation and also a bit to simplify uh
the comparison i mean you can like add
to the list at least 10 other ways of
uh doing the rate action selection and
even like
decision making in multi-armed bandits
uh okay so just a bit too
kind of historic example important this
is just like
upper confidence bound although i will
not directly compare it it has some
relevance to understand also what is
happening kind of in
active inference later uh
and this uh this form here uh just
corresponds to
a version uh which is adapted to
specifically bernoulli bandit so some
people might be more familiar with
other version which was derived for
gaussian
bandits right so this is kind of in this
paper here
one can see uh these different
derivations and examples
how how this works what is important
right to notice here is basically that
so this first term is just the expected
probability of reward on arm k
and the second two terms correspond to
this exploration bonus or the bound
uh and uh
so this is uh typical for ucb is that
the
bound kind of increases over time
logarithmic
logarithmically with the number of kind
of trials you're doing so basically
the more you're not selecting one arm
the more you're kind of pushed
again to select it at some point in time
in the future
all right so basically this necessarily
increases over time
uh if you are not interacting with the
specific r
right uh but still although like where
the algorithm is very simple it has nice
theoretical
results so because it's kind of it's
efficient algorithm
it converges in infinite number of
samples
however right here we'll talk on this
kind of asian variant
of the upper confidence bound which
actually make a
select arms based on kind of the
percentile uh upper percentage of
cumulative distribution function right
so so as
time uh progresses uh you uh
one is trying to estimate the uh like
the
extreme value of a believe distribution
which in this
case is just like a beta distribution
and and one one gets this extreme by
solving this equation which just
corresponds to
inverse regularized incomplete beta
function so basically
the more extreme point your beliefs
contain the more likely is that
i mean the more likely that you will
select that arm so
uh the more relevant is to select this
arm because you're expecting that right
uh this high value is still possible in
the
uh as a reward probability in this uh
in this setup and so but this kind of
algorithm has couple of parameters but
what
authors kind of show in this paper is if
you have
a very good results for just fix by
fixing c
to zero so basically this term just
becomes one
uh and so we we just
use their advice here in the paper so we
will not uh
and we didn't kind of try to analyze
other possibilities
or other kind of values of these
parameters in in the
uh in this case
uh so for um thompson sampling and this
is again one of the
classical algorithms first probably um
attempt with bayesian bandits so with
bayesian decision making
and it's also extremely simple right
given some beliefs
about probabilities at each arm you you
sample one point
uh so right if there are like 10 arms
you would sample from each arm one point
and
you will just select an arm which gives
you the
high largest values right uh
a variant uh of that which was shown
kind of last five to ten years that it
works slightly better is this optimistic
stomps on sampling
where uh one is constraining the samples
only to
uh values which are larger than the
expectation right so
so one is first making a sample from
each arm and then
if the sample is larger than the
expected probability
uh of reward then uh one keeps the
sample otherwise uh you just use the
expected value as uh
uh as a value a kind of a reward
probability associated with that right
and you're just again over different
arms maximizing taking the uh selecting
the arm which
gives you the maximum reward probability
but this is a kind of a very stochastic
approach
where this exploration actually kind of
bonus to this algorithm comes from
basically this random sampling from a
probability distribution and right the
broader your beliefs are about something
the more likely that you will get the
kind of large value
hence the more likely that you will
explore more
uh select that that arm uh
different runs and basically exploration
is kind of
here completely driven by uh the
noisiness of the sampling process itself
um okay so now we come to
basically active inference uh
version of this
so um we are kind of simplifying
here things from what people maybe know
uh
how active infrared is used normally so
first we will use like
rolling behavioral policies which means
that
agent is not like tracking history of
actions that perform
it just kind of a repeating step of
policies on every trial
and in this case the behavioral policy
just
corresponds to a single choice so
in this type of bandit problems we
we are kind of analyzing here like agent
cannot change anything in the
environment
hence planning is completely irrelevant
uh in a way you cannot kind of position
yourself in us
in space better over time so that you
kind of
need to plan something which means that
right
just kind of single choice policy
evaluation a single time step in the
future is sufficient to make uh
good decisions uh
and uh right uh uh generally expected
free
we will base our action selection on
expected free energy here
uh where this would be uh
a form which uh decouples into a risk
and ambiguity term but we can also think
about this problem as freight uh
estimating uh expected value of
of different arms plus the expected
information gain so how much information
we can extract from different arms if we
select
so
now let's assume that we know how to
compute expected free energy i will uh
go through details on next slides
uh normally like right posterior oval
policy
is is estimated as a kind of mixture
between
expected free energy so kind of a future
uh expectation about what behavior will
do
plus the kind of the second part which
is the free energy about the past
kind of outcomes however because we have
like rolling policies
this term is just constant uh
for each policy is the same it has the
same value basically so the posterior
policy or where action just corresponds
then to the
to the soft max right over the expected
free energy
uh and normally one one things like
uh about choice selection this is
assembly
samples from the posterior however we
are here only interested in kind of
optimal choices so for us
basically gamma is just infinite value
and we are just selecting the
uh making sure choices about actions
which minimize expected free energy
so this this is useful parameter to have
if you need to kind of uh
fit a model to the behavior but for this
kind of a
practical application there is not much
gain
in adding another source of noise here
um okay so how do we compute the
expected free energy right
well that's in a way quite simple so we
just
have a couple of terms here one is uh
posterior over
posterior beliefs over reward
probabilities right
given is this like q term this is just
the product of beta distributions
we have marginal likelihood so
probability of observing
o outcome given some action 80. so this
is just
marginalizing likelihood over uh our
current posterior beliefs
and another term is here just the prior
preference over
different outcomes right and this is
really easy to parameterize because we
we work with binary outcomes and we can
just define here a single parameter
lambda
uh so the higher the lambda is the
higher the preference
is of the agent to observe once
com relative to zeros right
and this uh lambda parameter also kind
of has a
role of regularizing the amount of
exploration an
agent does because the larger the lambda
is the more um
uh the more focus is uh
is set on the exploitation of kind of
making selections based on the expected
value instead of expected information
uh and so this final term right
computing ambiguity is basically just uh
computing expectation over the entropy
of different outcomes
right so which also has relatively
simple form here
uh because of bernoulli likelihood
so uh without going into all the details
this is basically how the expected free
energy looks like so this first term
here
is correspond just to the expected
negative of the expected reward
so because we are minimizing expected
free energy this effectively means that
we are maximizing expected reward
and the second term is just a very
complex sets of
set of like equations which
gives you estimate of the expected
information gain right
and the in a way kind of motivation is
just because one cannot really
understand what is going on here right
we have kind of logarithms of
expected uh reward probabilities but
then we have a d gamma function of
parameters and
uh so instead uh we can kind of try to
simplify the term by
approximating right effectively the
information gain part
uh just to get better understanding of
uh
how basically expected free energy
scales uh
like with repeated choices and uh so
what
one ends up with very simple form right
basically the exploration term
just corresponds to 1 over
2 divided by the number of time when
selected
different arms right so this is in a way
quite similar to
what what we had in the in ucb algorithm
right the like first exploration term
was also divided by something which is
proportional to how many times you
selected
uh an arm with but without write this
kind of
um x expansion of exploration bonus with
time so there is no logarithm of t
and i mean this will have a consequence
on
efficiency of active inference so i will
show you this in a moment
uh so how you wanna achieves basically
this simple form is just by
uh assuming that uh for large uh the
this the gamma function has this type of
approximation when x is
sufficiently large right so this just
means when you
sample sufficient number of time each
arm this will be
more like very accurate approximation
and we see that
this approximate so algorithm and the
exact they behave very similar so
it is in a way reasonably good
approximation
so you actually uh danielle i think you
asked like a question uh
about the scaling properties of this
right
one kind of uh
motivation for introducing approximation
is that in a way the algorithm is much
simpler so it scales better so you can
kind of run it
on much more arms easier
uh however like right the advantage is
not huge so maybe
uh it scales slightly better but you're
maybe gaining like 10
or 20 performance in computation time
uh so it's not something like uh which
destroys completely the exact form
at least not in this example right
because the problem itself is simple
however it helps us a bit understand but
just get intuition what is happening so
and uh at least like right how the
exploration bonus changes with time
uh okay so
before i kind of just show some results
uh uh
like comparison of different algorithms
i want to introduce
uh just concepts which come from uh
machine learning analysis of multi-arm
bandits uh which people use like
just to kind of rate the uh and compare
different algorithms right
how good they are in in solving this
task
and this is done by using something
defining a regret
so basically uh regret is simply a
difference between
uh what you did at trial t minus what
was the best choice
that uh at that trial
and uh so kind of
uh assumption here is that there is some
oracle
which is solving the task which knows
exactly what was the best
choice in in every trial right
and so normally people kind of consider
two uh two quantities either a
cumulative regret which is just
some uh of of regret
over or up from first trial till the
current one
or a regret rate which is just the
average over time of cumulative regret
right
and we will here use both just for
visualizing different aspects of the
algorithm uh and a kind of in stationary
case at least this is a very kind of
important result
because all for all good algorithms one
would expect that this regret
goes to zero over time right so as you
go to
infinite number of trials you should be
able to
always do like a good choice
uh and if this is the case then one can
show that uh
algorithms which have this property they
are called also sympathetically
efficient
and they scale for large t's as
something
some terms times a logarithm over t
right
uh and so this is kind of um
uh one important aspect of uh
a slice for stationary case of different
decision making algorithms
so multi-arm bandit algorithms so they
should
at least scale as logarithm of t when
you expand
uh right when you go to large till limit
otherwise right this first thing will
not
probably hold well or they can also
scale slower than logarithmic but
for example if they increase linear
limit t
this will not hold anymore
uh okay so um
now let's go to the comparison right uh
we will look into how the misting
thompson sampling bayesian upper
confidence bound
exact different inference algorithm and
the approximate one
uh compared to each other uh
i will start first with just trying to
see what would be kind of a good value
for this lambda parameter
uh in different settings uh
and also to give some kind of initial
comparison of
exact uh algorithm and the approximate
one
so what we are i'm showing here is a
regret rate right for different kind of
snapshots
so these dotted lines are after 100
trials
uh the dotted dashed line is after a
thousand trials
and uh the solid line will be after 10
000 trials right
and so what one kind of
notices here is that there is some
obviously kind of minima for different
lambda so this kind of
preference parameter uh
and that the longer kind of uh well
the more trials you do the smaller the
lambda should be so this this is not
quite nice and this kind of has a
consequence
however we can like just pick some value
which
uh so for example this purple dotted
line shows like
around 0.1 lambda 0.1 which seems to
have
be close to minimum for most of these
cases right so we don't want to kind of
have different value for different
examples because i mean this is just not
practically feasible
you want to have a kind of general
algorithm which can be applied to many
different situations
at the same time so
what when we compare so bayesian ucb
domestic thompson sampling and just the
approximate active inference so
i'm just excluding this here the exact
one because
they will behave the same pretty much
for this specific parameter value
if we compare them in terms of
cumulative regret
we see that right the approximate active
inference is not asymptotically
efficient so this
curve just goes diverges over time
uh where's those if if you if you look
at the
kind of the great uh sorry the green and
the yellow curve they they kind of
flatten out
after some time and they get the slope
proportional to this dotted
lines which actually shows the slope of
this kind of uh
asymptotic limit right what you should
see for large t's
now uh so why is this happening so the
thing is that
um because this exploration
bound is kind of just decreasing over
time
uh active inference algorithm kind of
gets stuck
into the wrong solution with some
probability which depends on the
difficulty of the task so right
the smaller the epsilon is uh the more
likely and
the more arms you have
sorry for smaller epsilon and for small
number
of arms there is a higher probability
that you get kind of stuck
right and one can see this if kind of we
take a snapshot
of of different runs so this is kind of
a distribution of cumulative regret
i'm just plotting the logarithm here so
like
making a histogram of over different
runs of this is like
10 000 runs of different algorithms
and just showing at what value for the
logarithm of the cumulative regret they
end up
as you can see here there is for kind of
active inference based uh algorithm you
see this kind of
well spike here and in the tail of the
distribution
which is proportional to just doing
random choices so that means that
basically algorithm was just selecting
wrong arm constantly
it never it never converged to a correct
solution
in a way it gets stuck into a rock
solution because the exploration bow
was reduced to too soon
uh right so in it
so this is kind of uh say limitation or
application of active inference to
stationary problems
because this is not the feature of an
algorithms you would like to have
in a way uh normally if
if you're kind of so example of this
would be
for example optimization problems that
you want to find
the best solution for a set of
parameters
uh now for example
by asian optimization finding the
minimum of what some unknown function
uses a thompson sampling this is kind of
seems to be a very efficient way of
finding the minimum however if you would
apply to such situation
an active inference basis um kind of
arm selection or sample selection uh
there is a chance that the algorithm
fails right you just kind of get stuck
in the wrong
minimum wrong optima it doesn't do
sufficient exploration
uh so this kind of uh requires
potentially some adjustments to how
actions are selected in at least in the
stationary case
uh so just to
okay
strange yeah i got some string slides
just to kind of
uh know a bit uh what the short term
behavior looks like
so from the perspective of kind of
cognitive neuroscience or like
human decision making you don't really
care about this asymptotic limit
because you don't usually expect people
to be in a either
stationary environment things always
change
or write that they kind of have to
repeat actions
so many times so what i'm showing here
now just
in a very reduced example so if we have
only three arms
and we just use kind of different
epsilon values so
uh task difficulties what is the
probability that
uh for different algorithms that you
select actually the optimal are
and as one can see that right initially
so by asian ucb for first maybe 25
trials
has the highest probability to select an
arm however there is a range of trials
like from
50 to maybe 1000 where
active inference based algorithm takes
over so right
in a way because of this information
game
term active inference is more efficient
in uh
targeting like the arms which will give
you the most information has
hence it can recover uh the best arm in
kind of some intermediate interval with
the highest probability
however as you kind of expand this after
like thousand trials or so you see that
this probability gets stuck so it never
converges to one
unlike the other ogre this is especially
evident for this difficult right
difficult problem small
epsilon and and so this is uh
in a way explanations of what happens so
basically algorithm although
it reaches good solutions after
it's hyper higher probability than other
algorithms
there are still a lot of uh um
lots of examples so in this kind of
simulations uh
parallel simulations which get stuck to
a wrong
solution and they cannot get out of this
so in a way right this kind of asked
question okay what can one do
to make active inference also synthotic
efficiency so how can the
maybe either generative model be changed
to
support increasing the exploration bound
over time
or maybe introduce kind of instead of
computing
expected expectations in um
of expected free energy one can also
just draw samples
from a posterior and kind of also
compute this
these two terms like information gain
and similar to like thompson sampling so
right there are kind of
different ways one can think of how to
add uh
exploration bonus another third option
would be to actually
introduce learning of the lambda
parameter
so that lambda itself kind of goes down
over time
so it kind of goes towards zero uh
in with specific uh
uh specific rules however uh yeah
currently we don't have very a good
solution for this
so we just leave it to this that has a
uh obvious limitation of just applying
active inference to this type of
problems um
are there kind of maybe any questions i
think uh
this would be like the half where we
switch now to the
perfect the other
um if anybody has any thoughts
definitely
i could ask some things or also
we'll ask if in the live chat people
want to post any questions
but um how much longer of a presentation
did you estimate that you had so that we
could kind of
also address some general points here
during this point one
um well i don't think there is more than
maybe 20 30
minutes max i didn't really
uh gauge it but there is less less
slides in the second question
would it make more sense to go through
it quickly
here yeah or would it make sense to do
it in the
next weeks uh i see which i think uh
both are fine for me i mean maybe
additional 15 minutes
okay so we'll complete the presentation
and in live chat
and on the video chat here we'll compile
our questions and then
in the remainder after your presentation
today and then next week we can have
more
open discussions so please continue
thanks okay
okay so uh now we
go to this like dynamic non-stationary
problem
uh and on any trial uh
uh in this case right it's this very
similar setup on any trial an agent
makes a choice between k
arms again we are focusing on the
bernoulli bandits so
outcomes are either just binary
variables
however what happens here is that the
reward probabilities associated with
charm change over time right and we kind
of differentiate between switching
bandits uh where we will assume that the
changes happen at the same time on all
arms
and furthermore in switching bandits
they are kind of also called piecewise
stationary so there is like a period
where nothing changes and then there is
just one moment in time when
uh rewards reward probabilities on all
arms change
or uh we can think about a call of
another variant of dynamic bandits would
be restless bandits
where changes happen independently on
each arm and they are continuously
changing
over time so for example following a
random walk
i will only talk about switching bandits
but
from some testing i did
all the results generalized also to the
restless case
and in this kind of beside this
number of arms and the difference
between the best arm and the
other arms of kind of reward
probabilities epsilon and
k we have another task difficulty this
is the rate of change
or like just change probability so the
more often things change the more
difficult the task is first
especially if you have uh many arms
um and uh
i will consider like switching bandits
with fixed difficulty which
is just extrapolation of the stationary
case to
uh by introducing changes to about
to which arm is associated with the
maximal reward right
we will always have the same rewards on
on all arms it is just that from time to
time
optimal arm changes with probability rho
right
and in this case we have right just
three parameters which
uh define our task that's difficult
we can also think about switching
bandits with
varying difficulty uh which then just
means that
with probability rho uh the reward
probabilities associated with
each arm either remain fixed on the next
trial so they are just kind of
translated
or they are sampled uh sorry with some
probability
one minus row should be here right they
are staying fixed or with probability
rho
they are just sampled from a uniform
distribution in this case
beta distribution with parameters one
uh and in this
in this variant of the task right we we
just have
ks and row as a fixed uh difficult as
difficulty parameters
so active one kind of disappears so
you're kind of averaging over epsilon in
the task
um and just to give you an example also
we will not discuss this but how
restless bandits
uh setup looks like is basically you can
uh
uh you assume for example that the logic
transform of
of reward probability just follows a
random walk so it's just a
brownian exploration in the logic space
of the reward probabilities
and this would also require potentially
changing the generative model which i
will introduce but
it's not necessary so one gets pretty
similar solutions
and behavior so um
now uh to come back to
the example from before uh if we have
like
multi-arm bandit with four arms
uh the setup is exactly the same
and in addition we assume that the agent
has access to the underlying probability
of change so this is not something which
is unknown
this simplifies uh the
learning rules and belief update
equations
uh however one can extend this what i
will introduce today to
the setups where the probability of
change has to be
learned also or that the probability of
change is also something which changes
over time so that
right you can have to track how often uh
reward probabilities change in different
times
uh so this will be kind of example of
decision making in volatile right
environments uh
so uh to visualize the algorithm
and the basically the only difference is
practically
that now you have an effective
forgetting
of what you uh you know what what agent
learned before
and one can see this for example if you
look uh
uh on this square to the left
uh as kind of time evolves and agent is
selecting other arms
uh this value which uh
reward probability associated with the
leftmost arm
just decays back to uniform probability
right so in a way
agent is forgetting information or
expectations it had about
this arm and it assumes that with time
the reward probability beliefs about
reward probability will revert back to a
uniform distribution
and the algorithm is really a
straightforward
extension of what i already described
before
so the generator model uh now is
slightly more complex so be
besides the the likelihood
term so observation likelihood which
remains the same is just the bernoulli
distribution
now we have a kind of state transition
term
uh which tells us how reward
probabilities change over time so and
what this means is that if uh
one believes that there is a change uh
reward probability will be independent
from the previous values
and they are just drawn they just
belong to a uniform distribution so this
uh kind of prior
belief and if there is no change uh
our the transition corresponds to a
delta function which just means that
uh uh that the reward probabilities stay
unchanged from trial t to t minus one to
t
and finally uh like the prior on
each trial we have the same prior about
probability of changes and this is just
again a
bernoulli distribution with probability
rho
which we here we will just assume this
is a known parameter
to the agents right so uh
the problem here in like dynamic cases
uh you can still apply
the the bias rule and you can compute
the posterior
both for the change probability terms of
jt
and for the post marginal posterior
about reward probabilities however
as you see here the exact kind of form
of the posterior is
not anymore doesn't belong to like
conjugate
so the prior is not any more conjugate
probability distribution to the
likelihood
and this is not anymore a simple beta
distribution but it's
becomes a mixture of beta distributions
and as you are kind of evolving into the
future this becomes larger and larger
mixture of beta distributions which is
uh well practically intractable right if
you kind of expand this to
open any and the number of trials
so because of that we want to have
something which is a bit more efficient
algorithm
uh we can basically introduce a mean
field approximation
when we now say that okay our
probability distribution can be
described as a product of a bunch of
beta distribution and a categorical
distribution which
just tells us the probability of change
right on trial t
uh and uh
how one what what this corresponds to
here so basically uh
uh what is actually we are using here is
a bit of uh it's not a standard
variational inference so where you would
have to kind of compute the gradient
over the radiation free energy to find
the optima this simplifies the things
because you just need one step
to update parameters both about change
and change probability and about right
reward probabilities
uh
this makes it not super optimal so there
are better solutions how i can do this
but it's very efficient so and
in in the end for the bernoulli bandits
this is there is will not be much
difference uh you can use better
algorithms
by uh this gives you just marginal
advantage
on the long run uh just because the
the problem is very noisy and it's very
difficult to actually
figure out the correct choice so what
this
variational smile does so it was
introduced by basilic
uh in well quite recently
2021 uh
so they provide you a bit more detailed
justification for what i'm
what i'm saying here i'm just
paraphrasing paraphrasing a bit
uh how the algorithm is defined so
basically we can
associate the marginal about change
probability with the exact
posterior marginal because you can
compute this analytically
and then we use this as a
basically uh
known known belief about change
probability to estimate uh
to estimate re reward probabilities by
right averaging in the log space uh over
over different
uh prior beliefs about
reward probabilities right so basically
you're instead of
averaging in the probability space
you're you're kind of um averaging in
the in the log space here
uh what this kind of results is very in
a very simple set of update rules so
on the left side we just are just
showing how omega t
is updated and this is um
just correspond basically to
forming beliefs about change probability
based on bias factor
shown here right which is just the
likelihood between uh
observing ot given that the change
didn't happen and observing ot given to
the change happened
right at the current trial
and then using that estimate to update
uh your beliefs about different arm
probabilities
and basically um depending whether you
selected the arm or not so
right basically the omega term here
plays this a forgetting
rate so the uh the larger the omega the
closer to one so the
larger the probability the change occur
the more you will revert back to the
beta0 and alpha zero parameters so the
initial prior belief
unless you will depend on your current
uh current beliefs
from the kind of previous trial uh
and this also has a important limit like
right if the agent believes that there
is no change in the environment you will
you will revert back to the exact
inference and the update rules which we
had for stationary case right so
uh and that's kind of also nice thing
about this
algorithm it can be just generalized to
any
any knowledge about probability a change
probability
okay so uh the action selection
algorithms did not
change so so the learning rules will
change but
we are practically doing still the same
way of of making
action selection so for thomson sampling
there's a sampling from the posterior
beliefs
uh for the asian upper confidence bound
it's slightly different so we are
using kind of the mixture between
uh again the mixture of possible
parameter
values to estimate the inverse uh
because from the this predictive
posterior it's difficult to inverse it
it's a mixture of two
beta distributions so this is just kind
of approximation one uh can use for
bayesian ucb and for
action selection uh approximate uh
expected free energy one gets with
uh a very same uh
uh set of equations because basically
raw
row can just so probability of change
drops out
it can be incan being nor easily there
uh okay so now if we
do kind of the same uh comparison first
of uh
exact and approximate after inference
algorithms we see a slightly different
picture
to what we had before
first it seems that as you increase the
number of trials
and you kind of compute this regret rate
for this specific number of trials
the regret rate does not change so in a
way
algorithm converges very fast to a
specific regret rate and
for different and there is a clear kind
of
stable minima independent of number of
trials you're
you're exposing algorithm to uh
similarly again we see like very similar
behavior between
exact active inference algorithm and the
approximate right
and for this example i will just i just
kind of fixed
lambda uh to uh 0.5
so in it just seems to be
reasonably well uh valued parameter for
many uh
many situations which we see here uh
however so
here i'm showing for 10 arms if we
go to 80 irons the picture slightly
changes so it seems that
optimal lambda parameter although it
doesn't
change with t it changes with the number
of arms and obviously with all the other
row and epsilon all the other uh
parameters so this makes things a bit
difficult
and basically suggests that it's
important to kind of find
potentially a learning rule like
self-optimizing
way of of estimating lambda and there
there is some work
actually in active inference literature
which potentially has
solution for that so uh we just have to
test it out at some point
uh so however or we can still use the
same
value this does not uh influence
that much the performance later on so
what we see
when we kind of compare it to uh
approximate active inference with
bayesian ucb and
thomas sampling is that for a range of
uh
right settings uh after either with like
fixed
um uh advantage of the
of the best like reward probability
advantage of the best arm
uh we see that active inference is just
right uh
performs better
already after like 1000 trials or so
compared to the other two algorithms
this is uh uh just for different
change probabilities so for example row
0.05 corresponds to a change every 200
trials
it should be every 100 trials on average
and the last
step here is every 25 trials so this
would be the most difficult right uh
scenario so one sees is that kind of the
more more difficult scenario here's the
the differences uh disappear so you're
kind of losing the advantage
uh however um if sim okay similarly if
we
look at the if we fix number of arms for
example 240 and we
just change the epsilon parameter a
similar trend
is visible right that uh the more easier
the task is the
bigger the difference uh in like
non-stationary scenario you get
relative to to other algorithms
of course one would potentially uh
kind of destroy this advantage if uh
changes become very slow like every
10 000 trials or something where you are
kind of approximately in the stationary
stationary world right
and okay so this would be like this
switching bandits with varying
difficulty we can do the same kind of
analysis
for switching bandit uh sorry previously
we looked at the switching bands with
uh fixed difficulty similar analysis
can be done for varying difficulty and
uh interestingly one sees here uh
notes because epsilon drops out one sees
here uh actually for the
exact active inference there is like a
clear
minima which uh seems independent on the
kind of any of these parameter terms the
so rho or
k so basically we can fix lambda to 0.25
for the exact acting difference
algorithm and we can still keep for the
approximate
lambda to for the approximate active
inference algorithm lambda to 0.5
and just to right show what happens
here is that there seems to be like
invariant difficulty there seems to be
also advantage of using
exact active inference decision making
algorithm
uh it outperforms the approx
approximated quite clearly
uh in this settings and it doesn't
require a fine tuning in this sense
right for the range of problems you can
have much better performance with the
single uh
choice of lambda value uh
and again so the in this case
interestingly the easier the problem
becomes so
in this kind of quadrant the less the
difference
uh between algorithms is and the
actually bayesian ucb algorithm becomes
quite uh
quite efficient in these settings also
here right you see that
beijing ucb also achieves uh quite good
performance
interestingly much better than
optimistic thompson sampling which
for me at least i didn't found any paper
who
previously uh showed something like this
so yeah
this is also a bit probably new result
for
machine learning people uh
okay so just to conclude right
active inference does not result in
asymptotically efficient decision making
uh
additional work is required to establish
theoretical bounce and regret
and derived improved algorithms in
non-stationary bandits however
we see better performance
in comparison to other algorithms and
especially noticeable in more difficult
settings right that
you're kind of uh getting uh
in the more difficult task is you're
kind of forgetting the better results
a tentative to-do list for like next
steps here is like
introduce learning for the lambda
parameter establish
a really like kind of theoretical bounce
on cumulative regret so what
can one expect to see
given different choices of the algorithm
for action selection
uh based on expected free energy and
so right this would hopefully improve uh
behavior and stationary cast
a case and potentially also apply to
some like
real world examples so this kind of
right uh
in into in machine learning field i
would say right you know
this kind of recommendation systems uh
optimization problems and similar right
just to see how it performs in this kind
of scenarios
yeah yeah okay that
i would just like to thank all the
collaborators on the project
uh and the people who helped me with
different advices
and you can also uh
find the slides here and the code is
available
my github page i would just not
recommend to
use it in the next two weeks because the
paper is under revision and
i'm breaking stuff constantly yeah
awesome thank you you can unshare and
we'll
return to just um discussion for the
last
45 minutes or so here but thanks for
that awesome
presentation with always good to get
multiple um multiple times just to sort
of
see some of those figures in the paper
then also there are some different
figures and some different views so yeah
again anyone in the live chat is welcome
to ask a question
or anyone who's here in this jitsi
i'll ask um a question from the live
chat first and then if you're here in
the jitsi
please feel free to raise your hand so
um it's written in a live chat since the
bandit problem here
is not markovian does this mean that we
only need to consider
the current time to calculate the
expected free energy
uh why why is not the mercurian
well let's let's actually clarify what
makes a problem or a situation markovian
or non-markovian
okay so uh for example
uh the problem is markovian because the
changes are only dependent on the
last trial or the current trial uh
right so the reward probability in this
non-stationary case uh will
be a function only on the reward
probability in the previous time step
and this is what uh makes the problem
actually markovian so i i didn't
talk about there are non-markovians
bandits but this is not
what we are discussing here right it is
really just markovian
but this is not the case why you don't
need
well maybe yes actually i mean if you
would go to non-markovian
bend it then you would potentially need
to plan ahead for longer because
that would require that there are kind
of
dependencies between your actions and
outcomes which you observe in a sequence
and different sequences
might result in very different outcomes
so right
because here we are in markovian case
and uh
agent cannot change the dynamics of the
environment in any way
so it's in a way just kind of passive
uh sampler from the environment uh then
you just
there is no gain in planning ahead so
you can just re-evaluate your beliefs on
each trial
so it's kind of like a memoryless
process which you
brought up and then what would have to
change to maybe account
for situations where sequence of actions
does matter
uh so for example one could
introduce structural dependencies
between different arms
so that for example rewards uh
reward probabilities depends on the
location
and allowing agent only to
to select uh to make their choices from
the nearby uh
right kind of introducing spatial
dependency
that would be one example where then
depending on in which
part of the space i am in kind of where
i selected
one arm this limits me to what what's
the next arm which i can select and this
would require you to then plan
depending on uh where you should be in
different trials depending on how you
expect
things to change right
all right this this would kind of
introduce then uh
the requirement for planning
cool very interesting um
blue or dave or sarah wanna ask anything
otherwise i
have some questions
you mentioned a few industrial
applications
and a few ways in which people do use
the multi-armed
bandit this is just kind of like um a
logistical
question like what is the rate limiting
step in
those use cases deploying active
inference agents
is there a way to kind of wrap the
inputs and outputs of multi-armed
bandits
uh in a way that's sort of interoperable
like you talked about how the learning
rules were similar but then you
you juxtapose different action selection
approaches
so in the context of pipelines that
people are already using
is there a way to kind of hot swap
active inference
and maybe have it be deployed in
industrial settings very rapidly
well yeah i mean that would be one idea
i mean for example uh
if you have these non-stationary
problems and you have already been used
using thomson sampling for example or
even like optimistic thompson sinclair
as a choice of the algorithm in a way
you already have a way to
form beliefs about relevant aspects of
the
of the problem then you can like really
easily swap
right the two and you just can then
apply
the the difficulty just to figure out
how to compute basically expected free
energy
and test it out right for the different
generative model
that people might probably have
yeah uh again for
stationary problems that's maybe
trickier
it might work in some situations but
yeah
you you don't have this kind of nice
asymptotic guarantees that you will
always find good solutions
in a way it's an advantage of active
inference in a changing world like
people's
preferences for a given advertisement or
the the situation for
trading is always changing and so
it's a false allure to have something
that has
extremely well behaved behavior in the
asymptotic or infinite case because
we're not in the infinite case we're in
the finite and dynamic case
and so it's almost like the sort of
strong
pillar that purportedly is underpinning
these other approaches isn't so much of
a gain pragmatically so it's pretty cool
to hear about that
blue thanks for the raised hand what
would you like to ask
so i have a question that was left over
from the dot zero video and something
you kind of alluded today
in your talk can you kind of detail the
difference between the switching bandits
and the restless bandits i was like
unclear on like the timing of the
switching
in the switching bandits and then also
um just like a part b of that question
in the case of the restless bandits um
what are
are the similar like algorithms that are
optimal for switching bandits
also optimal for restless bandits you
had mentioned
the active inference was good but what
about the others that are commonly used
no it's the same right i mean
so
let's say in restless bandits the only
kind of
so in switching bandits we have like
piecewise linear problem or piecewise
stationary problem
which means that between trial one
and trial ten everything behaves
stationary and then when the change
comes
you're just getting uh new reward
probabilities associated with each other
right
for example that would be a kind of idea
of a switching bandit so that
between changes everything is like fixed
and the restless
bandit assumes that things continuously
change and
here the example i gave was one can
assume for example that
reward probabilities can be described as
a
random walk in this
in this logic space of the probability
so basically because probability is like
between zero and one
you transform into one constraint space
between minus infinity and infinity
you just have a then gaussian random
variable so to say
and then you back map it back into the
into the with the sigmoid function for
example into the probability space
uh and and uh so but so for example the
algorithm i show like for belief
updating you
one could also just apply it there so it
just one one doesn't know what would be
the row
so what is the change probability in the
restless case
so in that sense you would need an
algorithm which can also infer the
change probability
and the restless case doesn't
necessarily translates
to kind of potentially fixed change
probability
uh so it's a bit more
different problem so because the maximum
arm the changes between
right between arms which are optimal uh
do not follow specifically like
the same structure as in the switching
case so
uh one can either take a different
generating model which actually assumes
explicitly the random walk and like for
example
uh hierarchical duration filter is
something which one could apply there
but they're also uh like what other
belief updating
algorithms for that so the local or the
global
maxima and minima are changing in the
restless as well
yes yes yes so this would be kind of
this case of uh
varying difficulties over the relative
uh
probability between the best arm and the
second best arm
varies all the time
yeah i don't have
i could i could have just drawn the
lines
to show but i don't know i didn't do
that i i could hear that
i just don't have it right now something
to
illustrate this so one other thought on
the advantage possibly of active
inference is that with a deep
generative model using the same skeleton
of maybe even the same code it could be
possible to
do model testing between two different
types of bandits like what kind of
scenario am i in
or even have deep temporal models so
it could be extended in a way where a
sort of instantaneous sampler
might be led astray yes
yes yes i mean in principle you can um
any hierarchical asian generative model
which consists of multiple models
potentially you could
also write generalized to thomson
sampling
or by asian ucb i just wouldn't assume
that this would be very efficient
way to figure out which is the correct
model
which you should be currently applying
to the specific task and this is
potentially also where active inferences
uh would would provide an advantage in
such
scenarios right where you can also kind
of
learn about the generating model itself
better over time
and that made me wonder what would it
look like at the sort of human level as
we're making decisions that are
sequential
in our day our decision making what
would it
look like or what would we keep in mind
if we were going to be making decisions
more like an active inference agent than
like a thompson sampling agent
like what would be you know when you're
in the grocery store looking at the
cereals that you've had before or not
how would an active inference agent
behave differently um
just kind of wondering yeah i mean
that's a good question i mean we could
actually we have some data sets
which which we could use exactly
to ask this kind of questions yeah i
mean i don't have on top of my head any
clear answer um
what what would be your expectation sir
well i guess um it would tell you one is
a
or better tell you when is a good time
to try a different cereal
because you may like it even more
especially if cereal
recipes change over time
and yeah then you have some likelihood
to be stuck maybe
with the super bad cereal but also i
like you to
have the one you like most
yeah i mean i guess this exploration
wouldn't would be more structured in a
way more
directed right um
right like i mean when the ingredients
change you check the ingredients and
then now you've updated your likelihood
of
trying something new yeah all right i
mean
thompson sampling doesn't have directed
part of the exploration
just the random exploration
whereas they're here the focus would be
more and right directed
exploration and potentially
thinking how to add random
so yeah one other piece is like
we're often comparing and contrasting
active inference to
reward learning and reinforcement
learning so it's almost like
instead of making that decision based
upon the highest expected value
like choosing something proportional to
its relative value or always going with
the one with the best likelihood
of having the best tasting cereal there
can be some
other heuristic and so it opens the door
to just purely curiosity driven
sampling like i've just never had this
and it's not
even as much a reward maximizing
maneuver as it is just a purely
epistemic
gaining maneuver and then as we've seen
when there's a pragmatic and an
epistemic component
to the function that's being optimized
then
those decisions can kind of co-exist and
be put on a common grounding
unlike in a purely value driven
framework
where even the exploration has to be
kind of
coerced back into reward
yes mean so i think uh syed noor and she
had like as a first author she had an
interesting paper the mystify
active inference and they discuss a bit
about
learning the preferences themselves
right and what kind of consequence this
has and this kind of
puts a different perspective on
understanding what the reward is because
in real world you don't necessarily know
why should something be more rewarding
than something else but you learn
this over time and you just learn to
prefer
different outcomes they don't even
necessarily have to be
in somehow rewarding more in the
absolute sense
you just build experience with some
outcomes over others and you'll
start to prefer them and this
then appears as if you would doing
reward based
decision making but i mean it's actually
in a way preference based decision
making right
cool i i had another question about the
approximation of active inference
is that the only way to approximate
active inference are there
other moves that you could have made to
approximate
the sections that you did approximate
are there other pieces that can be
approximated
what can be swapped or approximated
but still retain this essential
structure of an active inference model
[Laughter]
um
well i don't have many ideas what else
one could do
i mean the problem is in this scenario
it's relatively simple
right but for example one can kind of
think of okay
given that we have a
to compute the expected information gain
and we are kind of learning of having a
way to
to estimate it efficiently like just
with this approximation
uh there is other way how you can
compute this just by sampling
and you can draw a couple of samples
from your beliefs and you get some
estimate on the expected information
right so this this would still be in the
kind of
active inference frame framework
but just like a different way of how you
actually compute expectations and what
they will
kind of represent there right you will
this would be a way to add a bit of
random randomness to the decision-making
process
i mean active inferences also general
enough to work with many kinds of
approximations right and you can
do approximations and many different
points but
as long as you they get some sort of
variation of free energy
i guess it's still within this framework
and
immediately separated the
inference part from the action selection
part but i think
actually you can use it as a model of
both
right and then you can do approximations
and different points in this joint model
and as long as you can still write down
a variation every energy
i guess it's a counter active inference
well i mean i don't know even if that's
necessary i mean i would say
any kind of bayesian belief updating
even if it's not specifically motivated
by variational inference
would it the consequence have minimizing
variational free energy once once you
compute it from some posterior which you
obtain
and i mean right it's it will still be
in a way
active inference so right in a way one
can replace
like smile variational updating with any
belief updating rule
and still keep the same
concept there so because we are just
getting a better bound
on the marginal likelihood if you have a
better posterior
so so what would you say you know anyone
is necessary or sufficient for
a model to be considered active
inference versus not active inference
just including sense and action or
perception
inference action or agents in a niche
or blanket states these things are
sort of we're in an overlap of venn
diagram with certainly many
classes of models different approaches
and is it like that blurry intersection
that we're looking at and that's where
action and inference
are being just applied together or is
there something unique or something that
we can use as a diagnostic
well i guess the difference would be
more than this kind of uh
this action selection i mean planning is
inferencing part not then
not necessarily as perception in its
inference because as i said
one can think of many ways how one can
solve that part
but kind of once you go into this
planning as inference part and
also concept that right your actions
themselves
will change beliefs and you will
choose actions which are the best in
changing your beliefs or what you want
to achieve
then this is like i mean idea of active
inference in a way it's uh
let's say it's circular
inference problem right
uh it's not in a way it's any
more so easy to disconnect in the
effects of choices and effective
perception
they all depend on each other and also
being aware of your
own uncertainties and i think
if you do standard reinforcement
learning where you just
calculate expected rewards i don't
think you're always aware of how certain
or uncertain you actually
are about your own generative model for
example
and then potentially with active
inference
it's easier to know which action to take
in order to better learn your model
very interesting it's almost like by
carrying and propagating our uncertainty
and having a self model of action and
learning
then we get that almost like second
order
cybernetics where we're acting
in a way where in the future we can
expect to learn better or expect to act
better
as opposed to just this hungry search
for the best action and then learning is
only a one-step
projection into like what action is
gonna be informative
right now uh what's the next wikipedia
article that's most informative
rather than what's like the trajectory
that i expect is going to be resulting
in more effective learning
or action again on a common grounding
so that's pretty interesting looks like
you have a thought though
dmitry no i mean uh
the yeah that that's i mean definitely
important part but i mean i would then
call thompson sampling would also
satisfy that beijing ucb right i mean
they all kind of
are any bayesian decision making
algorithm
would necessarily have to take into
account uncertainty
uh
if it's derived from a bayesian
decision-making theory but
yeah it is not that clear that by this
aspect that
okay the actions also have a consequence
of reducing your uncertainty in the
future and this is what you can use also
for
that's a gauge on which one which action
is better
so yeah um
subtle differences and not that obvious
always
it's it's one reason why we're so
interested in
in ontology and slowly scaffolding the
research so that we can actually
juxtapose different models and
understand
where they differ like okay they're kind
of it's like two road trips and then
this person just took a little extra
loop or
this bridge they crossed this way versus
this person you know
took a different route right here we can
understand like
you talked about the smile variational
updating but then just recently you
mentioned that there's
that's sort of like a module you can
switch out
so what is smile or
because i also noticed a very recent
citation
so what does it do or what is it
different in regards to other ways you
could have fit that module
in
i mean i have implicitly used smile for
years now it's just a very simple way of
updating your beliefs so uh
so the problem a bit with kind of uh
variational inference if you want to
find the
minima of approximate posterior you kind
of
necessarily need to iterate uh
through several loops like minimizing
the gradient uh
so following the gradient of the
variation of free energy right
and i mean this also doesn't make it
very efficient
uh in for
this kind of applications so for me at
least right this variation smile
approach
side steps this iteration so you can
kind of transform variational inference
into just a single update step
uh just because there is a way part
which you can
compute explicitly and you just assume
okay this is now my fixed belief about
that
and the other part which you need still
to update
through variational approximation
[Music]
uh and so this is i guess
a small advantage here
but as i said right there are other
approaches how you can com
update beliefs in these scenarios and uh
you know in the bayesian sense there can
also be more
uh optimal but they just bring you
closer to the exact posterior
so but i mean we tested these things
uh with some examples and
the story remains the same so there is
no gain on
making things more complex on that on
that
but one can also imagine that like in
different
environments better generality models
and approximation rules
would take you further so but for
bernoulli bandit this is just
not the case what kind of empirical
data sets are almost
whether they're open source or just
obtainable are amenable
to this kind of analysis like if
somebody hears about the algorithm
and they kind of want to see it in
action or play with it themselves once
you're
you know two weeks from the recording of
this when your code is available like
is it possible is your code set up for
more of a simulation or is it something
where
we can plug in a type of data set that
might already be structured
appropriately
uh it's currently just for simulations
but i mean one could potentially write
play out with different algorithms add
other algorithms
both under like a learning part and the
action selection
i mean that that would be super useful
for everybody
yeah if there are people interested in
that where that would be
our repository is open and welcoming any
contribution
it was part of the structuring of your
paper that
like made us excited to juxtapose
it with these other approaches is you
kind of showed that you can
directly compare active inference
alongside other models
obviously it's something we're coming
back to because that's the crux of the
results of the paper
is really the different dynamics as
time increased or as the relative
challenge increased as the number of
arms was changing
between these different styles uh
and the two styles of bandit so it's
kind of a cool thing that people could
both
build on directly what you're working on
but also
maybe more broadly instead of just a
single model being presented in a paper
people could just include multiple
types of models in their sort of
baseline paper
so that we wouldn't just have to read
the paper that says this algorithm works
well
we could see them directly compared
and that's something that more and more
papers are doing with active inference
yeah i mean the
the kind of also
the libraries we use is also this is
something
which was developed relatively recently
like
uh by google jacks it's kind of uh
acceleration for linear algebra algebra
libraries so which allows you to run
very fast
this code and it also integrates well
with the probabilistic programming
language so it's a
numpyro which was also uh
developed really recently so one could
be in practice
link this to any behavioral data or to
create some test data
uh very easily uh
with a few lines of code so yeah there
is also this perspective
what language is the code in one or
multiple
and then what areas of conceptual math
do you think somebody would want to know
before diving in
so the language isn't i mean like
program language is python and just
depends on as i said couple of libraries
like
jacks numpy very standard stuff except
the jacks that's that's
new so yeah somebody
interested in using it would have to
learn a bit about jacks but that's
a long term also useful so go for it
but from the matte side yeah i'm
well i mean maybe getting a couple of
introductions to multi-arm bandits that
would be kind of
a good place to start uh right there
there is a
there is a recent uh
quite recent introductory paper mostly
on blended which exposes
many different algorithms in the
stationary concept so uh
provides a bit insights about this uh
historically
historic way how they analyze uh these
problems
so yeah uh i would suggest that that's
the kind of potential
place to start cool blue
so i'm curious about this google docs i
haven't heard of heard about it but
like i thought google had their own
language like don't they have like
golang right isn't that google
or tensorflow right
well yeah tensorflow
yes they have tensorflow and i think the
basis is
uh similar xla
uh it's called like accel accelerated
linear algebra
uh for both tensorflow and jx
so what jax is is basically accelerated
numpy
so you can just run standard nupi
code and in pure python more or less
uh and get very um
so you you get for free like uh um
computational gradients so it's kind of
autograd
library so you can kind of the compute
gradients on very complex graphs
uh this is also something which
tensorflow allows you
but this seems to provide more more
benefits for this dynamical scenarios
so i have problems when i tried learning
or using tensorflow it's very difficult
to think
into right code which is dynamic there
and that's why i i never actually start
started using it i started with pytorch
at some point
and now that jax showed up that has some
speed up advantages it's also kind of
quite lucrative
so one code question just to stay on
this theme and then ask a question from
the chat
what about the um python implementation
like uh i think infer actively or
what alec chants at all have
worked on what are the similarities or
differences with their
python approach there
i think currently none because i'm also
involved in that so
they will also start using text okay i
guess
cool so that those threads will join
together
okay uh but i mean this also code just
like produces some of the
i mean one could also write use just the
spm code but this is super
complex uh right it would be super slow
so for example just to examine
numerically this stationary scenario
this
would take months probably too
[Music]
okay nice somebody's ranking
uh so yeah um
right that's uh uh that's kind of the
the problem there and this i wrote the
code to be kind of very efficient in a
way so just kind of
removes lots of complexity that you
don't need
cool uh all the right in some scenarios
you want to have general
uh description of the program so yeah
so here's a question from stephen in the
chat
do you think that parallel modeling
processes might be used more in the
future
with different model approaches
highlighting different patterns of
behavior
happening in different niche contexts
i would say in some ways it's what your
paper did but what are you thinking
about yeah
well i mean from practical side yes i
mean that's what
you should be doing because just figure
out what works best
and just don't don't think
too much about well the philosophical
side of things
uh but yeah but i mean i guess long term
one could i mean imagine scenario where
more and more things become
generalizable to this description
so it's just in a way a
difficult process takes time even for
those who are
just learning about the technical
details like the visual
tell for me was that the figures were a
grid
of graphs so it was kind of like
three different settings of difficulty
or three
or five different settings of arms it
wasn't just showing
we ran it with one parameter combination
each of those graphs was a grid of
combinatorics and then you presented
what i guess could be considered two
different niches
with the static and the dynamic and then
today in the presentation we
heard about all these other variations
and so those are like
kind of toggles in the code you can say
i'll take
no a1 alpha or i'll take
a2 beta as far as the combinations of
how to run it
and so as the code becomes more
interoperable
and pruned down to really the necessary
pieces
then it becomes easier and easier to
expand it back out
so that we can choose amongst different
options
for a given piece and so that's like
this skeleton
that so many variations flow off of
yeah um
cool well in our last few minutes here
where would you like to uh take it
next week or beyond i mean what are your
current interests or curiosities
well i mean for me it's just important
to have this paper out so next time when
a reviewer asked me
what about that and that algorithm i can
say okay look
we analyze this it's like that it's
similar or different
you can you can get whatever you want
basically there
uh right i mean because you have these
adapted parameters
in a way you can generate very different
behavior one can also think okay if you
have like an agent which
behaves as a thompson sampling what
would be the corresponding
parameter in active inference framework
which would emulate that
can you actually even differentiate
between them
so uh i mean this is uh potentially
interesting questions which
one can try to answer and which are just
from
my work kind of relevant because of this
constant uh questions i'm getting in
during the review process
uh and that was actually
yeah but then there is also this like
quite interesting side in like machine
learning
uh where this can find potentially quite
interesting applications
uh i i got started a bit uh
recently working with kind of monte
carlo research
and interestingly uh sorry this is
something which was applied in active
inference as a way to compute
expected free energy in complex problem
but turns out that
if you have kind of very complex
problems you can also
use thomson sampling in monte carlo
research
uh right so as a way to
just figure out what is the best
path to follow uh in a sample
and this potentially provides if this
stationary scenario can be improved
somehow and
uh this is also kind of you can apply
active inference to
planning inside active inference itself
you know in a kind of
uh hierarchical circular way though
right so what does that look like or
how does it get implemented or how is it
different than just
straightforward active inference
uh so the problem is like that when you
have quite a complex decision
making in a planning problem where you
have multiple
branches in the future which you have to
go it's like not practical to compute
everything uh so what people do is
a very popular way to do is like monte
carlo research
where you just sample different paths
you you
estimate us on a sub sample of possible
paths what is like
uh the best path to to go and this would
correspond in active inference like
you're
estimating expected free energy of a
path
in the future uh just through a sample
but then you have a problem okay how do
i select the same the paths
in the sample and then you can apply it
active inference
to the pet selection itself so right you
can kind of choose
which paths i should sample randomly
when i'm trying to approximate
uh expected free energy for this problem
itself
so that's kind of what makes it kind of
interesting is a possibility to explore
and the way that you just framed it
as well as what we've seen which is the
relative
strength of active inference in dynamic
settings
it's consistent with a lot of the
qualitative and philosophical ways that
people
are talking about active inference as
like a sense making
or a way finding or a navigation
approach
rather than a sort of cut and dry
calculus of decision making just
resulting in
the total you know crystal path just
being laid out before you
it's really about the instantaneous
actions that we take now
in light of uncertainty about the
present and really the past and the
future as well
so it's always cool to see how the
technical developments while they're
like kind of weaving and recombining
they proliferate and then we see oh
actually these three are kind of
interchangeable or these three are
complementary
and then we get more technical detail
and speed ups while we also get more and
more
clarity on what the structure of this
sense making problem is
yeah i agree
any final thoughts here from anyone
otherwise this was a super
interesting presentation and questions
so we really
appreciate it
thank you cool yeah thank you
yeah we're looking forward to for the
next week great
so thanks everyone for joining and
everyone's welcome
to join live for next week when we'll
continue the discussion
and the dot 2 is kind of like our
jumping off
into the the unknown unknown instead of
just the known unknown
so thanks again for joining and we'll
see you next week
thanks bye bye